Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
Dragon Ball superhero movie review I was able to
go to the US Premiere there's a lot of deep cuts
and references to all the major Dragon Ball series
going back to the first one and to the previous
movie Dragon Ball Broly so I will explain where
this movie fits in the timeline if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos it's been a while since I've done
an anime video I think the last one I did was
for Attack on Titan season 4 a while ago and then
the Dragon Ball Broly movie way before that it's
been about four years since that movie came out
that's how long it's been don't you feel old now
technically the movie is called Dragon Ball super
super hero but you can call it Dragon Ball super
hero too if you want to it is meant to be part
of the Canon timeline the main series it's meant
to take place after the events of Dragon Ball
Broly but not that much time has passed after
Dragon Ball Broly and really like the most notable
thing that everyone's probably going to be talking
about aside from all the big power upgrades that
everyone gets that's usually what everybody talks
about but the other major technical aspect of the
film that people will be talking about mostly will
be the the animation style the animation style
for this movie is a huge change it's more 3D
computer animation and CG as opposed to the Broly
movie where they did use some CG for sure for the
fights but Broly was animated in a more classical
2D hand-drawn style like it was meant to look more
like the old school Dragon Ball series this time
the entire movie is 3D CG animation it didn't
take me out of the movie or anything like that
their implementation of it is getting a little
bit better like people are actually getting better
at incorporating into this series so if they wind
up using it for whatever the Dragon Ball super
sequel series winds up being hopefully they'll
have got a little bit better by then but it was a
little bit weird to go from watching Dragon Ball
Broly to this 3D animation style like it was a
seismic shift I do kind of wonder if they were
using that as a test run for this animation style
for the Dragon Ball super sequel series they will
be doing another regular Dragon Ball super sequel
TV series in the next couple years or so the next
year or two I don't know what the exact premiere
date is going to be or exactly what the plot is
going to be or if they're going to be changing
a bunch of stuff for the manga but there will
be like a next Dragon Ball series that will take
place later in the timeline and incorporate all
the stuff that's happened to the characters so far
the second big thing about the movie is that it's
more of a Gohan and Piccolo movie than anything
else like if you felt like Gohan and Piccolo got
the short end of the stick the last several years
in the Dragon Ball super series with the character
development then this movie is like the answer
to that like they both get huge power upgrades
and when I say it's mostly a Gohan and Piccolo
movie it's mostly one of those types of movies
where like all the regular Mains that you would
normally see be the leads in movies get sidelined
for the entire plot so that the quote unquote
other guys so to speak like the backup team
basically has to handle all the main villains so
there were a couple contrivances like how come
Goku isn't here like where's Vegeta what's going
on with Broly like they do explain that during the
movie but they're very on the nose with the way
that they sort of sideline them so that it has
to be a piccolo and Gohan Adventure pan is also a
big part of the plot if you felt like she hasn't
got a whole lot of character development then
last several years there are tons of references
to the major arcs going all the way back to the
original Dragon Ball series when Goku was a child
like they try to go back to the beginning of
Dragon Ball with some of the original arcs to
reference what's happening with the villains in
present-day to sort of tie things together across
all the series including Dragon Ball Z we're kind
of in that era of Dragon Ball where there's been
so much Dragon Ball in order to keep the older
stuff relevant they try to incorporate it in the
plot make it meaningful for the plot of the newer
stuff which I do think is kind of cool it's kind
of like being a Star Wars fan or like a Marvel fan
or a DC fan where like new movies include Easter
eggs for like really old classic stuff and if you
haven't watched those old Dragon Ball series in a
billion years or you never watch them or you
just forgot about a lot of those arcs in that
plot they include a very a very long recap of a
bunch of different characters and arcs to explain
what's going on with the villains in the movie
The main villains of the film are mostly Magenta
in the red ribbon Army which is a big deep cut
to the classic Dragon Ball series it's been so
long since I watched that Original Dragon Ball
series I definitely needed the recap for the Red
Ribbon army stuff the other really big deep cut
is bringing back cell they do a huge recap of the
cell Arc from Dragon Ball Z and bring him back as
Cell Max he becomes the real big bad of the movie
the new characters they introduce are Dr hito
the grandson of Dr Jiro the person who created
Android 17 and Android 18 and then eventually the
original cell during Dragon Ball Z so like at the
beginning of the movie a portion of the big recap
was for the cell Arc so that you remembered all
that relevance in the movie jiro's grandson has
become a scientist as well who's kind of morally
ambiguous gets himself thrown in prison but isn't
totally evil who also loves creating the perfect
Android and he's the person who winds up creating
these two new characters here both Androids Gamma
1 and Gamma 2. like I mentioned earlier Goku
Vegeta Broly and Broly's new Squad from the
Broly movie are all in the movie briefly though
like very briefly they're really in the movie Just
for continuity's sake like what's happening with
the main characters since the events of Dragon
Ball all Broly like I said because it's mostly a
Gohan Piccolo movie they had to create a reason
to keep Goku Vegeta and Broly off-world the entire
time because they're way too powerful right now so
they just had to find a way to take them out of
the story basically so because of that big plot
shift like because this is kind of a movie about
the side characters technically I mean Gohan and
Piccolo are main characters but they're kind
of treated like Side characters now because
it was just about them and it had so many really
obscure deep cuts to Classic arcs really it felt
like a smaller movie than Dragon Ball Broly like
it wasn't quite as epic a story as Dragon Ball
Broly was just because so much of Broly's story
goes into the mythology the origin of the Saiyans
the origin of all the main characters the origin
of the Frieza Force Dragon Ball super superhero
didn't go quite that deep like it was mostly
a side quest to power up a couple neglected
characters from the Dragon Ball Super Series but
it was still very entertaining like if you're a
big fan of Gohan's character and you have been
really upset that they kind of sidelined him for
so long in Piccolo as well because Piccolo is
supposed to be pretty powerful anyway they do
really shy during the movie they give them some
huge power upgrades but if you haven't seen the
movie yet just do be prepared for it to feel like
a much smaller story but one of the great things
is them paying off a lot of those deep Cuts Like
if you remember way back to when they introduced
the prophecy about how Gohan was supposed to
surpass both Goku and Vegeta as like the most
powerful member of their race but then Dragon
Ball super kind of decided they weren't going to
deal with it like you know what we're just going
to come back to this at some point in the future
we need to focus on developing this new Ultra
Instinct stuff right now we're mostly focusing
on Ultra Instinct right now and introducing the
Broly character who himself is also supposed to
be really really powerful it was satisfying to see
them finally pay off all those bits of Mythology
about Gohan's power levels and at the same time
give Piccolo the massive power upgrade that he's
been due for a while Piccolo's new highest form
they're just calling orange Piccolo when he said
it out loud in the movie it got a big laugh in my
theater Gohan's new highest form is being called
Gohan Beast I think that's just meant to be a
clever wink at their race turning into bees so
to speak under the light of the Moon and becoming
way more powerful but it's not like he turns into
an actual Beast it's sort of like his version
of an ultra Instinct form but I think because
during the movie Piccolo very literally talks
about him being the most powerful saying like
being way more powerful than Goku and Goku has
gone Ultra Instinct I think they're trying to
say that Gohan's Gohan B's form is also now more
powerful than Ultra Instinct I am sure when they
get to whatever that next Dragon Ball super sequel
series is they'll find a way to keep Gohan from
going straight to Gohan beast in all his fights
it's the same with Goku and Vegeta going Ultra
Instinct like they try to keep the power levels
kind of under control so they try to make it seem
like it's a super rare form that they take like
they can't hold it for that long the music was
pretty good if you like the music in Dragon Ball
Broly the music in this movie was fairly similar
even though I definitely needed some of that recap
for some of the super deep Cuts I did like all the
references in Easter eggs they tried to include
if you've been a fan of the series for a long time
like if you're a super fan of Dragon Ball then
you'll probably recognize way more stuff than
I did and because this movie felt kind of like
a side quest to power up a lot of the neglected
characters I wouldn't be surprised if they do this
with future movies as well just because there's so
many new characters that they keep introducing
to the team the level of fan service in the
movie was about on par with normal dragon ball
movies like it was a little bit of fan service
and because there are so many long-running tropes
like the Dragon Balls themselves or like Shenron
they included the obligatory jokes about some of
those long-running things like at this point the
actual dragon balls are kind of used so often
they're like party favors so there are a lot of
jokes about characters misusing their wishes on
trivial things and they give Shenron a big Power
upgrade too so like Shenron himself also becomes
more powerful during the movie so I believe he's
permanently now at his new power level but no big
spoilers about what that power level is there is
a post-credits scene so make sure you watch after
the credits whether you're watching in the theater
or you wait to watch it at home so it's more
like a funny joke kind of post-credits scene
but they do pay off like a really really long
running reference once you do have a chance to
see the movie just post all your reactions in the
comments below and when that new new Dragon Ball
super sequel Series starts in the next couple
years I will try to do at least a couple videos
for it but I have no idea what the plot of that's
going to be yet or when it's going to start only
that they will eventually do it one of the few
things that you can count on in this life is they
will continue making new Dragon Ball till the end
of time and even though avatar The Last Airbender
isn't technically anime it's like Western
animation inspired by anime they did confirm
that they're making three new avatar The Last
Airbender films the first one is going to be with
older versions of the character after the events
of the book 3 finale of course I'll do videos for
that when it releases Mike and Brian are also
making a new animated avatar The Last Airbender
TV series of course I'll do weekly videos for
that too I also believe that the Avatar The Last
Airbender Netflix series which is live action will
Premiere next year good or bad whatever that winds
up being I'll do at least one or two videos for
that we'll see how that live-action Avatar goes
we're all kind of crossing our fingers and hoping
that it's not terrible big reminder too my Marvel
She-Hulk episodes will start next week you can
click here for my brand new She-Hulk Daredevil
trailer video and click here for my Ant-Man 3
trailer video from Comic-Con in Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!